i know that you've seen our beautiful
kitchen
on the set many times but i actually
wanted to take you guys backstage
you want to come come on it'll be the
first time
we actually have this kittler prep
kitchen tucked right behind the wall
and my friend todd is back there waiting
for me
so todd is someone that
i've celebrated many many important
moments of life with
there he is there's todd
it is like so like great to be here well
todd you and i have worked together for
many years we met through jill kargman
and todd is an amazing mixologist
i'm actually going to teach you today
how to make some drinks
that's going to be nice because usually
i'm just accepting them from you yeah or
you try to make a drink
which is a total disaster i've tried to
whip a drink for people
and they taste bad well we're going to
teach you how to make a good one
what we're going to do today is we're
going to make you this really amazing
halloween themed uh drink that i came up
with
it's called a ghostly pumpkin punch and
i really love like a festive food or
beverage that gets us in the halloween
spirit
pun intended and that's why we're also
so excited to team up with lg
a company i absolutely love who
outfitted our backstage test kitchen
with all these gorgeous appliances to
help us make some
spooky drinks and snacks and you're
going to be able to actually go on our
website and get todd's recipe for the
ghostly pumpkin
punch and it's delicious so the first
thing is just kind of just kind of like
kiss the
the rim of the glass with some honey
todd i have never
thought of putting honey as an adhesive
on the rim of a glass well you're going
to see
why it's so amazing so then we're going
to switch over to the cinnamon sugar
all right and then you should have
something that looks pretty beautiful
what do you think yeah there you go you
did it it doesn't look as nice as yours
but it's
it's good we're gonna take our our
shaker
and we're just gonna start building the
drink a little bit okay so i'm going to
be using
uh this right here is a whiskey rye but
we're going to make a mocktail for you
so that right there is an apple cider
perfect and just put it all in this is
also good training for
what i'll make olive and frankie later
tonight oh my goodness
yes uh so we're going to squeeze all of
our lemons
all three of them squeeze of the lemon
so now we're going to do this is like
the real uh secret to this
this beautiful drink so yeah you're just
going to take the whole pumpkin puree
and you're just going to kind of
pop it right in there pumpkin puree
pumpkin puree
so you can get it in uh in a store
canned if you want but we got fancy and
i
roasted yes i did i roasted just for
today
you're so amazing you're such a unicorn
are you kidding you roasted
and pureed a pumpkin we did it just for
you drew
i love you so then we're going to take
our spoonful of some ginger
which is just some minced up ginger and
just put it right in there
i love ginger yep and then uh
where we got and then we got some honey
just kind of scoop
up a nice little healthy spoonful of
some honey yup you got it
uh and then last thing a little bit of
cinnamon that smells so good okay so
ground cinnamon
like what do you say like half a
teaspoon exactly
this is a drink that must be shaken
don't stir it up
get it and this is going to be a kill so
you really got to learn how to shake it
very nice right that's a really
gratifying cause it's very nice
okay so uh so what we want to do now is
we want to pour it over ice but check
this out
the lg insta view refrigerator
automatically
makes these amazing craft ice spheres
check it out no way yes and they are the
perfect size for cocktails
and they're slow melting so your drink
is never going to get watered down
so now we're going to do is we're going
to take our drink and you're just going
to pour it over
okay as is yeah
so we have a little bit of space because
we're going to top it off right here
with a little bit of ginger beer
non-alcoholic just called ginger beer
wow this looks so beautiful then we're
going to garnish it with a little
cinnamon stick
like oh my god goodness yeah oh my god
it's so good what may i ask i mean this
is a mocktail
is there anything else for like kids
that they can interact with
yes absolutely so um so i also uh put
together a really great age-appropriate
mocktail that's called a goblin gauntlet
a goblin gauntlet
so what you're going to do is you're
going to start off with this is an apple
soda it's green apple soda you're going
to pour that
all in oh um and then what you're going
to do is
oh my gosh it smells really fresh it's
like green green apple yeah
it's a real deal we're going to put a
little bit of water in because it's
going to get a little sweet and i always
like to cut it with
just a drop or two of water because our
next step is we're going to pour some
spooky lime syrup
and then the topper is this cranberry
juice and what you're going to do is
you're going to try to aim like
right for on top of that ice cube oh my
gosh
look at that oh that's really cool
oh todd did you bring us a snack as well
oh uh yes so um
guess what we use the lg insta view
range that allows you to air fry your
food without the guilt
so what you could do with your
countertop air fryer you can now do
with the oven so what we got is two of
your favorites so we have
sweet potato tots and we also have
cauliflower bites
so you can just like dig in all right
here we go
ready mm-hmm all right oh and cheers
let's do it
um cheers todd the whole thing
yeah cheers
that was so good well todd thank you
so much um and i want to thank lg
for helping us set up this kitchen so
[Music]
beautifully
you